they will be met with fire and fury like
the world has never seen he has been
very threatening beyond a normal state
and as I said they will be met with fire
fury and frankly power the likes of
which this world has never seen before
thank you thank you thank you all right
so that's exactly what Sara Mary just
reported out Gloria what you were mirror
mid-thought good go ahead well I mean
look you saw the president I mean he was
very somber he was very determined
clearly angry they've threatened us now
that we threatened them back and you
know the question is does this ratchet
up or do we find a way to calm everyone
down to avoid something that could you
know that could result in the use of
force
you know at this point